Good morning, Hank. It's Thursday. Hank, I just got to my hotel room in
Kalamazoo Michigan and you know what was
waiting for me here?
Strawberry Hill, Peeps, and Nerds.
Thanks Kalamazoo. And all evening long
I've been thinking to myself what is it
that America wants to see me do with
Nerds, Peeps and a bottle of Strawberry Hill?
And then I realized: what America
wants to know is whether or not a Peep will
float in a glass of Strawberry Hill.
Will it float? It floats.
Look, it's a little ducky on a pink pond!
So there you have it, Hank. Peeps float in
Strawberry Hill. But wait, you say, do
Nerds? Hank, as you can see I have a lot
of grape Nerds and now we are going to
test them. Mmm, that looks delicious.
Well, Hank. The answer is that Nerds
do not float except for the lone Nerd that
attached itself to the Peep. Smart Nerd.
Hank, many people say that Brotherhood 2.0
is not educational, but I would
argue that it is educational, because now
we've all learned an important lesson,
which is that if you find yourself in
the open ocean with a thousand Peeps
and a thousand Nerds, you should cling to
the Peeps and let the Nerds go.
In profoundly disturbing news, it seems that
Strawberry Hill turns purple Nerds white.
Let that be a lesson to all of you.
If Strawberry Hill can strip purple Nerds
of their color, just think what it can do to
your gastrointestinal system.
This is something from the comments.
We're gonna miss you, Ze. Peter writes: "What
if your efforts to decrease suck levels
actually makes suck levels increase?
What
is the contingency plan, we need an exit
strategy here". Hank, just like Peter, I'm
profoundly concerned that we might
accidentally increase suck levels. If you
think about it, most of the suckiest
things that ever happened started with
an attempt to decrease suck levels. Like,
for instance, you have to say that on the
whole the steam engine has been a pretty
good thing, but then on the other hand it
sure was warm yesterday in Colorado. But
here's the thing I'm thinking, the worst thing
you can possibly do is not try to
decrease suck levels. After all that's what
the first Brotherhood 2.0 book club
book was about. In our lifetimes we're
all gonna do things that accidentally
increase suck levels, but the true
nerdfighter is awesome enough to say: "You
know what, I've made a mistake, I
increased suck levels worldwide but I
didn't mean to. I'm sorry, and I think we
should change course
so as to decrease suck levels in the
future". Hank, that's why I'm grateful that
so many people in the American
government are true and awesome
nerdfighters. Oh, wait, crap. I'll see you
tomorrow. Happy birthday to you, happy
birthday to you, happy birthday dear... I'm
gonna let Hank finish the song.